speaking of Trump's followers Trump has
rebranded his followers
magadonians in an all-caps erratic truth
social post truth essential yeah Trump
posting quote we are magadonians we are
very smart we stick together as one we
follow truth social essential we put
America First and we will make America
great again
posting this apropos of nothing just out
there randomly turning on caps lock and
posting this nonsense Trump giving
advice to Fox News as well quote this is
in all caps Fox should embrace Maga
their Prime Time viewership is down 37
percent from just a year ago all because
the very smart even brilliant
magadonians know that despite all the
fake lip service Fox News is pushing Ron
Des Sanctus or anyone else for that
matter because they hate the greatest
America first president to ever put on a
suit and tie me they are all globalists
and globalists will never make America
great again so going conspiratorial
completely unhinged completely off the
rails and these are the sorts of claims
that I guess his followers are still
desperate for all of that has been in
capital letters continuing in capital
letters attacking Alvin Bragg prosecutor
in New York saying quote wow legal
experts are saying that D.A Alvin Bragg
will be immediately forced to drop his
weak and disparaged case against quote
Trump because his top investigator
Jeremy Rosenberg corruptly colluded with
the disgrace disbarred and convicted
felon and perjurer in attempting to
frame me with a crime that doesn't even
exist they apparently became close
friends with lifestyle money spent a
crime this on top of Clinton lawyer
turned prosecutor Mark pomerance
illegally writing a book on the case
this is a former president of the United
States this is a man who says elect me
again give me me another four years and
I will solve all of your problems the
very problems I didn't solve when I was
president the first time and he wants to
do it while claiming everybody has
turned against him he's the biggest
victim in the world and that he actually
won the 2020 election at a certain point
folks you know I said it earlier Chris
Christie is so obviously the best
Republican candidate running right now
but the Maga people don't want them if
the Maga people in 2023
look at who's running and they say oh I
want Trump trump is what makes sense I
believe Trump I believe Trump will do
the things he's saying if that's what
they believe they deserve to get Trump
as their nominee and to lose badly
really badly the problem is we can't
just look away and assume that Trump
will lose because it's not at all
obvious that Trump will lose and that's
maybe the scariest part of all of this
after the break we will talk about
what's going on on the Democratic
primary side you might be saying what
Democratic primary we will talk about
that after the break
one of our sponsors today is fume not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad part
from your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning device that does exactly
that fume is not electronic there's no
Vapor or harmful chemicals fume is just
a delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fume success story head on over to
try fumed dot com and use the code
Pacman to save 10 when you get the
journey pack which comes with the device
and three flavors the link is down below